[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this
year-end edition of these impromptu
live q and a's that we have been having
december 31st 2020
wow sort of hard to believe so happy new
year
and other parts in the world now that
have already crossed over into 2021 so
congratulations
you have successfully navigated 2020
left that year behind a year that many
of us are all too happy to
have in the rear view mirror as we now
go forward with a degree of optimism
from
many sectors of the world
at the moment and i'd like to spend a
little bit of time today you know
obviously answering your questions doing
a bit of wrap up of some of the
scientific developments over the last
year
and let me begin
with just taking a couple questions from
the live stream let's see spin foams
wants us to have equations in today's
session i don't know if
you know i don't really have a capacity
right now to write in real time in these
live sessions it's easy for us to do we
just haven't really set it up so
unlikely that spin foams is going to be
happy by the end of today's session
but we'll talk about some real stuff
even if the equations themselves won't
be with us
let's see avid hut d
what you thought on girdle's
incompleteness theorem
what i thought on girdle's
incompleteness theorem i think it's a
good theorem
it's a stunning result establishing that
there are qualities of the world
in the mathematical sense that we can't
establish
to be true within the system of the
mathematical
assumptions the axioms within which the
statement is articulated an interesting
question is does that incompleteness
that inability to prove
every statement that is true to prove
that it's true within a given system
does that then spill over to physics
are there qualities of the physical
universe that will forever be beyond our
ability say to
understand or to prove in that sense
because of this incompleteness theorem
people have debated this issue a lot
over the decades
and you know the the approach that has
always struck me as
particularly interesting is of course
girdle theorem
relies upon certain assumptions right
any
theorem that you prove itself has a set
of assumptions that you make
and one of the assumptions is that we're
working in the
standard form of logic standard
axiomatic form of logic but there are
other
kinds of logics
there's a logic i forget the exact name
i think it's called paraconsistent
logic that's a logic in which a
statement and not that statement
can actually both be true but not the
conjunction
of them in the sense that normally if a
and not a are both true you can prove
anything right if one plus one
equals two and doesn't equals two if
those two statements are true in a
system then you can use that to
basically prove that any statement
is true now
if you have this para consistent logic
that wouldn't be the case
you could have a statement and it's
negation both
be true and yet it wouldn't explode into
a morass in which
everything can be proven true and false
maybe in some deep sense
that's the way the world is maybe
it's a different logical system than the
one that critical use it's just one idea
that people have floated around
so i don't know i don't know the full
implications of girdle's ideas
for physics it's a it's a subject that
has been discussed but i wouldn't say
it's at the forefront of most cutting
edge
physicists thinking about things but it
is definitely worthy
worthy of attention in terms of news
before we get into some of the things i
want to discuss in more
detail based on your questions wherever
they go i couldn't help but notice
i don't know if anyone saw this article
in new york times today
dennis overby one of the great science
journalists yeah there it is um
i was talking about this observation
of a signal a tight
beam sigma very constrained within the
frequency range within which the signal
is vibrating as well as the
directionality in the sky
the signal seems to be coming from
proxima centauri
proxima centauri that's the star
couple stars closest to sun about four
light years away and
as you may know yuri milner
philanthropist who's been supporting
research and science physics also search
for extraterrestrial intelligence
has been supporting researchers to try
to scour the sky
and find signals of extraterrestrial
intelligence and you know when a signal
like this pops up
the natural thought is you know maybe et
is out there now as dennis overby makes
clear in the article
that is not the explanation that most
people are
thinking of you know it could be some
kind of
human generated radio interference that
we are mistaking
for some source coming from much further
away but it's always exciting you know i
whenever proxima
centauri crops up in this guise it can't
help but
capture my attention i think some of you
may know
i wrote a short story years ago about
a boy who is on a mission
to rendezvous with the first life that
we have made contact with
beyond life on planet earth and indeed
the signal is from proxima centauri so
be kind of cool if uh if that story were
to have some basis in reality
the article today is not suggesting
that's the case but it's exciting at
least that there's a
signal that's anomalous we love
anomalies anomalies are the kinds of
things that
really really keep us going in science
most generally
so if we're thinking about the year in
science look the most important thing
that we can point to of course
is this small miracle maybe large
miracle
amazing feat of researchers to develop
19 vaccine and for it to be
put into use before 2021 i did not think
this was
possible when there were claims of that
sort being floated around it seemed
fanciful to me that we'd be able to make
progress that quickly so
hats off to the researchers who have
succeeded in groups of researchers of
course as we all know there are a number
of vaccines that
are now showing enormous
promise and that of course is the
proverbial light at the end of the
tunnel
for where we have been for the last year
so from the standpoint
of scientific breakthrough scientific
achievements
that that vaccine certainly is one that
deserves
our enormous praise and it's one that of
course will have a
great impact on the world going forward
so that's sort of in the
the big breakthrough i'd say in the
realm of
medicine realm of biology chemistry as
well because of course
the approach that was used requires a
tremendous
amount of the breakthroughs that have
been achieved and developed over the
past few decades at
being able to understand the micro
physical
microchemical processes
by which our cells operate and to learn
how to manipulate
and control those processes so that is a
fantastic achievement in the say
biology chemistry life medicine domain
in a completely different kind of
research there's another
breakthrough that i suspect many of you
have read something about
which might be called in the um the
biology chemistry artificial
intelligence
domain this is this breakthrough that
comes to us from
deep mind you know this company them is
hash abyss
brilliant researcher who's been
heading up a team that has been looking
at one or many problems but
well i should say more generally what
the idea is to have some
systems that are capable of analyzing
large data sets
and from their ability to spot patterns
and leverage patterns in those large
data sets be able to
achieve things that previously we deemed
the
purview of biological intelligence human
intelligence right this is the team
responsible for
alphago this artificially
intelligent system that was able to
become a champion in the game of go
merely by you know studying
a huge corpus huge data set of games
that have been previously played as well
as learning to play the game against
itself
and through the patterns of
understanding
the pieces on the board and their
implications
for whether that
configuration would lead to a win or not
the system became
within a short period of time able to
beat
some of the world's human experts
at go so using that same kind of
approach
they took on a problem that has
befuddled researchers for many decades
it's the
protein folding problem i remember i
first heard about this problem i was in
high school
i think i was in high school and i was
visiting i think i was visiting
colleges or something visiting princeton
or something i remember one of the
students there
was doing a senior thesis on the protein
folding
problem which is this idea that you know
protein
long chain of amino acids the question
is
what's the 3d shape into which
that protein folds which has a profound
impact on
the mechanism the role that that
protein can play within a cell
and researchers have really struggled
with this for
a long time and again deep mind by using
the same approach
of pattern detection
in large data sets and being able to
manipulate
those kinds of insights they you know
some people have said they have now
solved the protein folding problem i've
not spoken to them directly i suspect
they wouldn't say that they've
solved the protein folding problem but
they have made tremendous strides
in unraveling that because they've been
able to now
use their computationally based system
to predict
how a given sequence of amino acids will
fold and then compare it to how they
do fold in the real world and i think we
have a little visual
that we can probably bring up yeah so if
you see here if you look down at the
bottom
the green is the experimental result the
blue is the
computational prediction and you see
that these shapes they agree
with each other right the computation
in the real world and this is
being widely hailed as
a real profound breakthrough in
trying to come to the full resolution of
this protein
folding problem so we think back on 2020
yeah there'll be some bad stuff
but uh that result will certainly
be among the great results of this year
and it you know it suggests that going
forward
this approach will have the capacity to
give breakthroughs in other arenas
i think we're going to have a
conversation with dema's hassebus at
some point the world science festival
perhaps in the
in the next coming year and
i know from a conversation i had with
him around march
one of the things that he wants to focus
these kinds
of ai systems on are some of the deep
problems of physics i mean protein
folding is a physics problem
it's relevant of course chemistry
biology of course but ultimately it's a
physics problem
how does this collection of particles
arrange in this particular chain of
particles
what is the dynamics that ensues
once that collection of particles has
been
linked together and that's one
particular physics problem there are
many other physics problems that these
ideas can be applied to so it's a very
exciting
set of developments going forward and
definitely worthy of uh
great praise as we wrap up 20 20.
in astronomy uh many great things that
you could point to astronomy i'm going
to just point to
one it's actually a a breakthrough
that is due at least in part in large
part to
a colleague of mine at the center for
theoretical physics at columbia brian
metzger
we should have him on the show one of
these days too and this is his problem
having to do with these so-called fast
radio bursts these radio waves of a
great intensity that
astronomers have observed popping up
here and there
throughout the cosmos and people you
know
creative scientists came up with all
sorts of potential
explanations and who knows maybe some of
them are right
but certainly not clear yeah people
suggested
evaporating black holes that's a subject
we're going to come to in a moment but
at the end of a black hole's life
since the uh temperature of a black hole
we discussed this in the conversation
both with roger penrose and lenny
sussman the temperature goes like one
over the mass as the mass
gets ever smaller the temperature is
ever bigger so at the end of a black
hole's life there should be this burst
of radiation maybe
that people suggested could be the
origin
of these radio bursts cosmic strings you
may know about these cosmological
defects
topological defects that can form
yielding a a linear structure of energy
if that
linear structure would somehow snap
there could be a burst of
energy perhaps carried in radio waves
from those
that's a possibility of course going
back to dennis overby's article today in
the new york times
whenever you have a strong radio
signature it brings to mind the
possibility that it is some alien
civilization that's sending out a signal
to us so these are the kinds of things
that people threw around
but by carefully analyzing new data
brian metzger and his colleagues
they came to the conclusion that the
fast radio burst is
likely at least in the case that was
recently
observed due to a magnetar this is a
i think we have a little picture of one
of these yeah there we go that's pretty
these are neutron stars which are as you
know these very dense
stars they're not quite black holes not
at that
level of compact object but you know
very very dense objects
sometimes these guys have very powerful
magnetic
fields and that's where this name mag
and guitar comes from
and at least in the case of the fast
radio burst
that was recently observed the belief is
that
this object this kind of an object is
the source so it's not
the end life of a black hole it's not a
snapping cosmic string it's again
not et phoning us but rather
an exotic and very intriguing source
of these radio signatures so
that i'd say is a real exciting
development
in astronomy but obviously but we like
to focus our attention here on for the
most part is physics
and i'm going to be guided by some of
your questions going forward let me just
talk about one
that came up in the conversation
with roger penrose
we didn't discuss it in great detail oh
sorry about that
[Music]
i've got a a phone call i'm gonna turn
that off and try to put this phone so
that is a very amateur hour
type of thing for me to allow happen but
you'll cut me some slack here
that it's uh that it's new year's eve so
i'm gonna not gonna throw my phone out
the door but i'm gonna try to put it
someplace
where i can't actually see it okay put
that to the side
all right good um so what we're
referring to
is with roger penrose we discussed this
issue
of the quantum measurement problem right
the quantum measurement problem
and um remember that's a problem that
in quantum mechanics the formalism tells
us the probability of getting one
outcome
or another in any given observation any
given experiment
but the formalism does not tell us
how we go from that probabilistic case
to one single definite outcome and when
we ever whenever we observe something
whenever we do an experiment we see one
definite outcome
so the question is how do you get one
definite outcome
and there are all sorts of ideas that
people have come up with
we've discussed some of them there are
these d ideas of the
the mini world's interpretation of
quantum mechanics maybe they all happen
in different realms
there's the so-called copenhagen
approach which is not really an
approach it just sort of says don't
worry about it
just use the quantum formalism as a
predictive tool
to get the probability of this or that
outcome but don't use it
to describe the transition to that
definite outcome that's kind of a
cop-out
most people have largely come to the
conclusion
but many people i don't know where this
idea originated
i've seen it in the writings of richard
feynman
there are others as well penrose has
certainly
developed this idea further which is
that
gravity must have something to do the
suggestion goes i
underscore suggestion the gravity must
have something to do with the quantum
measurement problem
well i mean at some level that makes a
lot of sense right because
in the little world of particles they
can certainly be
in two places at once i put that in air
quotes you know what i mean by that
the probabilistic formalism can give
them a chance of being at one location
and a chance of being at another
location
and that doesn't blow our mind because
we don't directly see electrons
so if the mass says the electron can be
in los angeles
and in new york city because the
probability wave has
non-zero value at those distant
locations
that's like mind slapping it's weird
but it doesn't cause any direct
tension with everyday experience
because we don't experience electrons in
that pristine isolated form in everyday
life
if i was to say that you know i can be
at two places or that there's a
probability of me it being a two
distinct widely separated location
that's
far stranger macroscopic body
so if it's not so much
of a mind crash for
us to imagine electrons in this
superposed state but it is such a mind
crash
for larger objects maybe it isn't true
for a larger object
the suggestion goes maybe when things
get
big the superposition
principle of quantum mechanics doesn't
hold maybe that is when things are
very massive the superposition principle
does not hold therefore maybe
gravity that thing that responds to mass
is intrinsically part of the way
in which the measurement problem is
resolved
things are big and massive the kind of
superposition
that we're used to for electrons doesn't
hold that's the idea
and again feynman said something like
this as a possibility penrose has
developed it
the question is can you test this idea
and that's an interesting question and
one that
you know many people thought you
couldn't and look it's it's difficult to
test the idea in all
generality there are many flavors of an
approach in which gravity can play a
role in resolving the quantum
measurement problem
but there is one idea that penrose
himself
championed at least in one form or
another
that at least now has been tested
to some degree i think penrose would say
well there are variations on
the theme of even that approach and
the experiments were only able to
make headway on one particular approach
so it doesn't rule out the idea because
as will no
show i don't know if we have that paper
here of these underground yeah
underground test of gravely
gravity related wave function collapse
wave function collapses his idea of
going from
the probabilistic haze to a definite
reality often we talk about in terms of
the collapse of the wave function
not all probabilities that the math
allows to be
out there maintain their non-zero values
they collapse to zero
upon some kind of interaction or
measurement so so the idea here was to
see
we can keep that up and keep that paper
up for a moment the idea in this
experiment
was to see whether there could be an
observational
impact of gravity inducing
this resolution to the measurement
problem
and how they do it well the idea is
according to some versions
penrose's initial version of this idsa
if gravity is indeed what causes the
wave function to disambiguate
to give one answer not many answers to
collapse all the other
possible answers their probabilities all
the way down to zero gravity does that
then for a large enough sample it should
be doing it to all the particles within
that sample and it turns out that that
would yield
a kind of spontaneous creation of energy
within
the object as particles sort of snap out
of the quantum haze and take on
definite positions and so these
researchers
looked for those signatures and
they didn't find them in this particular
case
and i should say of course obviously all
experiments just set
limits you can't rule anything out
usually
completely you just set limits but the
limits are such that the original
proposals
seem to be in tension with the data and
that's kind of cool so
it looks like a first step in the
direction of trying to test some of
these esoteric
ideas about gravity related
disambiguation of the wave function
gravity related solutions to the quantum
measurement problem
not a positive answer as yet but
it's nice to see these ideas being
confronted with experiment nonetheless
and i believe it's the case
that penrose is developing or has
developed
another version of this idea in which
that creation of energy would not
be a part of the theory and if that were
the case then of course the
experimental results would not have any
impact on that other approach so it's
not like
the gravity related
explanation has now been ruled out but
one version of it
is in tension with the observations
okay so i call that kind of a fun i mean
the quantum measurement problem is like
a deep deep problem in
our most basic theory so anything that
begins to give us
some experimental hint of that i i
salute
and i think is well worth keeping in our
list of interesting
results in 2020 but certainly
the most exciting developments that i
would focus upon in a year-end wrap-up
are those to do with black holes which
is why our
two guests of the two previous sessions
were
roger penrose and lenny suskind roger
penrose
the black hole singularity theorems for
which he just
won the nobel prize so that's that's
hugely exciting
and lenny of course as we discussed in
our last
session with him was this and continues
to be this great force
in thinking about black holes
the information that falls in how it
comes out
does it come out and if so how does it
come out all those issues of
holography and entropy and so forth and
a number of you have written
questions to me even post that live
session
i want to get to to some of those
so let's um let's spend a little time on
black holes and i
there are some questions i've seen
already in the chat
both here on youtube also some of the
facebook and twitter
let me just get to some of those
yeah our first question here sheila from
oklahoma
asks how did stephen hawking realize
that black holes have
entropy that's a good question sheila
but
i actually frame it a little bit
differently
it's not exactly that stephen hawking
realized that
black holes have entry historically it's
a little bit different right i mean
you know it was john wheeler thinking
about throwing a cup of tea
into a black hole wondering where that
entropy would go it was wheeler talking
to a student
jacob beckenstein or is it beckenstein
i'm never sure
about that so i'll call it beckenstein
sorry if i'm saying that wrong
and and wheeler asked back and seen what
gives with the second law of
thermodynamics if we can use a black
hole
as this ultimate garbage can for entropy
we can dump all disorder in the universe
into a black hole
then how do you have the second law of
thermodynamics how can you ever talk
about entropy increasing if there's a
garbage chute that you can sort of dump
entropy
out of the universe into the black hole
where you'll never be able to see it
again
and it was beckenstein not hawking it
was
beckenstein who initially realized
that when you throw a cup of tea or
anything else into a black hole
you really need to continue to ascribe
that entropy to the universe because the
black hole itself simply
imbibes embraces that entropy the black
hole itself can have and does have
entropy that was beckenstein's not
hawking that was beckenstein's
inside so if you don't mind sheila i'm
going to change the question to
how did how did jacob beckenstein come
to this conclusion and
we actually have a i'm going to describe
it in words first give our team a moment
we do have a visual
that we've been developing for another
program it's kind of a sneak peek of a
program we're going to be doing in the
fall
uh no in the spring i guess we're in the
fall right now
but um let me describe it in words and
hopefully they can put their hands
on on the visual here's the idea here's
what beckenstein did he said look
if he got a black hole the real
interesting question is how does the
black hole respond when you dump
entropy in now he wasn't going to throw
in a cup of tea if this is all
mathematical of course not like
beckenstein
is uh going to a black hole let's
actually uh you got the visual thank you
but let's not bring it up
let's not bring that visual up yet let
me explain in words first because i
think it's uh
too hard but fantastic that you guys uh
able to put your hands on it
so so the idea is so beckenstein says to
himself
what if i throw a single unit of
entropy into a black hole single
universe how will the black hole respond
now how do you have a single unit of
entropy
he says well look imagine i have a
single photon
but a single photon doesn't necessarily
have one
unit of disorder you can think about
again
entropy as we discussed previously with
lenny and
roger it's kind of a measure of the
hidden information content now if you
have a photon going to a black hole
there's a lot of information in
principle
did that photon enter the top the bottom
the left the right
all that information about where the
photon enters so beckenstein says
i just want a single unit of information
so i kind of want to blur
out the photon so that information is
not available how do you blur out the
photon
make its wavelength roughly the size of
the black hole
so kind of smear out the photon so the
only information you ever have is
does the photon make it in the black
hole or doesn't it
just one yes or no question
is all that you'll be able to ask about
that scenario
so so beckenstein mathematica imagines
having this
blurred out photon okay that he throws
into the black hole
and mathematically he then analyzes what
happens
and what he finds is the black hole gets
a little bigger that's not surprising
black hole eats energy energy's like
mass
the black hole size is proportional to
its mass so if it eats a little bit of
mass to get a little bigger good
but how much bigger and he finds that it
gets
bigger its surface area gets bigger by
basically one plank area
one plank area so you throw in one unit
of
entropy and the area of the black hole
goes up by
one unit in these plank units
and that leads him to the idea
that the entropy of a black hole is
accounted for
by its area throw in one the area gets
bigger
buy one throw in two it gets bigger by
one or by at least by one now we can
show that little visual you can bring
that up
so here's that that smeared out photon
you see it on the left there and if we
throw that photon
into the black hole it's all smeared out
so it either gets in or it doesn't
imagine it gets in
the black hole gets bigger because it
just ate some
energy and now we're going to calculate
visually how much bigger so there's the
area of the original black hole
take all those tiles these are all plank
area
tiles let's use them to tile the new the
slightly bigger
black hole and see how they do in terms
of covering it and you see
they cover it say for one little
plank area which means that the
old black hole that's the one
which at least is on my left i never
know how left and right work here but on
the left side of the image
is the old black hole the right side of
the image is a new black hole
and you see the new black hole is bigger
than the old one because the
red tiles that perfectly covered the
original black hole
they're one short in covering the new
the bigger black hole one unit of
entropy in
area increases by one
unit and that's how beckenstein
comes to this idea that when you talk
about black holes
the amount of entropy that they contain
can be accounted for measured
by represented by the number of these
red tiles the number of these
planck area tiles now you may be
familiar
the actual number is usually area
divided by four
in the units where c g and h bar equal
to one
for the technical those among you who
follow this in detail
but look if you redefine the blank area
to be plank area
as normally defined divided by four
that's what that's the rational way of
thinking about things
then each of those tiles has one planck
area
and the total entropy is just the number
of tiles which is just the area
of the surface the horizon
of the black hole measured in these
planck units so that is the answer
to how beckenstein not hawking came to
this idea
of black hole entry now hawking then
came along
didn't believe this idea frankly was
motivated by trying to rule it out
but he goes much further when he tries
to rule it out he actually establish it
from a different perspective and then
comes to all sorts of other
wonderful conclusions about black holes
having temperature and black holes
radiating
and so forth and we can spend a little
time
talking about that so tan zoo asks
what is inside a black hole besides the
singularity
and look in the traditional way of
talking about black holes
things fall in ultimately get crushed
into the center they don't
instantaneously go to the center the
singularity
so there could be things inside a black
hole
and route to the singularity but once
the
black hole is settled down let's say you
stop allowing things to fall
into it then yeah what's inside the
black hole
is this central
point at least mathematically where the
math breaks down the curvature goes to
infinity the curvature goes like
one over your distance to the sixth
power
from that point and the distance here is
actually a temporal distance not a
spatial distance because space and time
interchange their roles
when you cross over the edge of a black
hole but basically there's nothing there
except for the singularity which is why
it was so surprising
when beckenstein made this suggestion
that
black holes of entropy because normally
you know if you've got a
a box of gas and you remove all the gas
the entropy inside now let's say it's
completely empty the entropy
in the usual way that we think about
statistical mechanics thermodynamics
goes to zero
you need the gas you need the stuff
inside of the container
in order for the container to have
disorder
but if the black hole think of it now
like the container if it
kind of doesn't have anything inside
except for this
singularity as tanzu asks about
like what's holding on to the entropy
and that's why it was so surprising
and at least part of the reason why i
think hawking was
so skeptical that this idea of black
hole entropy
was true black hole seems so thoroughly
simple
right simplest thing you could imagine
basically empty space with the
central singularity that we don't really
understand
but where could the entropy therefore be
carried
that was a puzzle and that's why it's
still
surprising that black holes do have
these thermodynamic
properties um
take another questions about this i'm
i'm particularly
favoring questions that have to do with
with black holes uh here's another one
from
neo chrysler i hope i'm saying that
right neok
neok risla neo chrysler i don't know um
let's see
um if black holes at centers of galaxies
can have billions of times the sun's
mass
wouldn't they immediately crush
everything around them
well i get the um i get the intuition
neo chrysler
big is usually better stronger
more powerful with black holes the
intuition is kind of reversed
the bigger the black hole the more
gentle
it is in in a very specific sense
and you can measure that in a number of
ways for instance think about the
the density of material that you need to
have to create a black hole
right right you may recall
and this is good for i'm sorry who asked
for equations that would have been
spin foams all right spin foams an
equation
i want to actually write it down but in
the formula for black holes that
initially came out of the work of carl
schwarzschild back in
whatever 1916 remember russian front
world war one schwarzschild gets
einstein's manuscripts often i describe
it as fortuitous strange that he got
ahmed signs man he was actually friends
with einstein so it's not all that
surprising that he got the manuscript
but
it's more romantic to imagine he's just
out there and
somehow mixed in to his marching orders
from
the military they slipped in
accidentally einstein's
paper whatever put that to the side but
schwarzschild writes down
the first exact solution to einstein's
equations
einstein himself did not get the first
solution to einstein's equations
schwarzschild did and in that solution
he writes down the metric for what we
now
call the schwarzschild metric the metric
for spherically symmetric massive body
and the key term in that formula
involves something
of the form 1 minus 2g m
over c squared r the real thing is there
2g m over c
squared r why does that matter well
putting all the
constants to the side that term is
relevant because when
r equals m or 2g m whatever but put
you know those constants aside basically
when r is equal to m
that metric has a zero in it or an
infinity depending upon which term
you're looking at
and that's where the black hole edge the
black hole horizon the notion
comes from now that's important because
r is say proportional to m
which tells us that the short style
radius the radius of say
a black hole is proportional to its mass
why does that matter well think about
the density
of an object that will become a black
hole
density is mass per volume
put mass upstairs now i guess i'm
speaking to
spin foam and a few others who don't
mind the mathematics
put the mass on top what about the
volume volume goes like r
cubed four thirds pi r cube say you know
if you're in flat you put in space for
the volume of a sphere but if r goes
like m then r
cubed in the denominator for the volume
goes like m cubed
so m over v goes like m over m cubed
which means it goes like one over m
squared the density goes like 1 over m
squared
1 over m squared which means that the
bigger the mass
the smaller the density the smaller the
curvature not the bigger the curvature
so amazingly you know if you have a who
asks that question
neochrysla so if you have a
if you have a black hole that say has a
billion times the mass of the sun right
those are the kinds of black holes that
are at the center of
galaxies not you know milky way we got a
puny
black hole you know four million times
the mass of the sun but other galaxies
have billions of times the mass of the
sun so
take it to be a billion if you put a
billion solar masses into that formula
for the density of a black hole just
work it out i i don't know the exact
number
but it comes in at less than the density
of water a black hole can be formed
by bringing together a billion times the
mass
of the sun in a volume such that the
density is less than the density of
water and that will then collapse in on
itself to create
a black hole and if you again take the
density to be
for the black hole it's mass divided by
the volume
out to the event horizon you're talking
about
a very low density very small curvature
so
contrary to your intuition that black
holes the bigger they are the more
monstrous they are the more curvature
they have
it's actually in this sense the reverse
the more gentle they are
the less dense they are the less
distortion they create to the space-time
environment
around them so it's really as the black
hole gets smaller and
smaller that the curvature goes up and
up the temperature goes up and up
the reverse of what
you would think um harshad
kailas pel mahale
that's quite a name fantastic
your view on white holes so white holes
are kind of time reverse versions of
black holes
black hole things fall in white hole
things are
continually coming out and
you know most you know people tried to
rule out these so-called naked
singularities
unsuccessful ooh excuse me
pardon me unsuccessfully today
to to have a mathematical proof i don't
know
i don't think we really know you know
maybe we'll come upon one of these
strange objects
one day they're certainly allowed
by the laws of physics just time reverse
versions of black holes but
certainly no observational evidence for
them to exist so i just don't know the
answer nobody does
um occam's razor asks i want you to
explain
quantum where is it i i
sorry um ankan's razor you were so
efficient in your question you so pared
down the language
allah occam's razor that i don't
understand the question
want to explain where is it sorry i
don't know what it is
um e key e e c
k e e could you talk about the inside of
black hole through the er
equals epr view oh boy that's a great
question
um how do i do that well
let me see um
let me get i'm gonna work my way
e e key to that question i see another
one here that will help us get there
terraformer terraformer asked can you
just give me a straight answer to
whether or not something can actually
fall
into a black hole a straight answer look
straight answers are
what i strive for all the time
sometimes questions are really subtle
and having
the kind of answer that you anticipate
you know yes or no may be itself
misleading in some sense whether or not
an object falls into a black hole
depends upon your perspective
if you are the object falling into the
black hole then you will
at least in the traditional way of
thinking about black holes
you will fall in you will make it to the
event horizon
and in short order depending on the mass
of the black hole
the size of the black hole you will find
yourself increasingly uncomfortable
as you get ever closer to the central
singularity
you will fall in
if however someone is watching you at a
safe distance
heading toward the black hole their
perspective on what happens will be
different and this has largely to do
with this weird property of black holes
which i don't know if we spent much time
talking about here
but time slows down near the edge of
a black hole time slows down
why is that it's sort of hard to explain
but
the basic idea is that gravity doesn't
just pull on
matter it doesn't just pull on energy
gravity in a sense pulls on time itself
or even more precisely
gravity is
the warping of time gravity is
manifested by the fact that
clocks at different distances from a
gravitational source will take off time
at different rates
i think i got a visual can we bring up
do you have that visual but the cl yeah
wow full service look at this so you got
two clocks
in this little image they're far safe
from a star
like the sun and at this distance if we
allow their second hand to start ticking
right you'll see that the clocks because
they are right next to each other take
enough time at the same rate but now
bring one clock closer and closer and
closer
to the star now it is ticking off time
more slowly you can't see it really
because there isn't enough
gravity for it to make a difference but
if you take that sun
and now imagine crushing it down
into a black hole that allows us no more
mass but allows us to take that clock
and bring it closer to the source
and the deeper the clock goes into the
gravitational well the stronger the
gravitational potential
the slower the clock will take look at
the second hand
on the clock that's right near
the black hole there it's tick enough
time incredibly slowly compared to the
second hand
of the clock that's far away look at
those two clocks
ticking off time at different
rates actually i once wrote a short
story
based on this idea i don't know if any
of you've ever read this icarus at the
edge of time
about a boy going to the edge of a black
hole it turned to a stage show
i'm actually working on the sequel to
that right now so it'll be it'll be out
at some point soon so you can see the
whole thing but anyway put that to the
side
why does this matter for the question
that uh who asked it
terraformer wants a straight answer to
whether or not something falls into a
black hole
why does this matter well look if i am
far away
watching you with your watch fall toward
the black hole
and if i'm looking at your watch i will
see your watch tick off time slower and
slower and slower
which means that your progress toward
the edge of the black hole will be
slower
and slower and slower which means from
my perspective
i will just see you get closer and
closer to the edge
but right as you get to the edge your
clock basically stops your progress
through
time from my perspective stops
and so from my perspective you kind of
hover at the edge if i'm being a little
bit more precise you'll be
deeply red-shifted the light that you
are emitting
will have its wavelength stretched out
making it ever
redder in color ever more spread out
so i will see you kind of spread out
along the event horizon of the black
hole and i will never
see you fall in so
again from your perspective you fell in
from my perspective the outside
perspective
i see you hover at the edge
so the answer is i mean that's the
answer
it's an observer dependent question so
you know you should get in the habit i
mean i'm not i'm not a great fan
of neil niels bohr's
view that if you can't frame a question
in terms of
a measurable quantity about the world
it's not a question worth asking i don't
go that far
i think there are many interesting
questions about the world that speak to
our
mental image about how the world works
but here's a
case where taking a niels bohr
perspective is a good one
phrase your question in terms of an
observable
quantity and so from the perspective of
the observer falling in the inside
perspective
yeah you fall in from the perspective of
the measurements observations of an
external observer
well i don't see you fall in and that
is as far as we
can go and so so that's part
of the the mystery and in fact that
takes who was it
iki sorry iki asked about the er equals
epr stuff
yeah i mean it's a great question um let
me see if i can again continue to work
toward that answer with
i mean that's part of what we need to
get to the answer
what else do we need to get to the
answer well
okay so one of the big puzzles
that lenny suskind gerard tuft many
others were struggling with in this
picture of black holes and entropy and
information is if you throw something
into the black hole
from outside right what happens to the
information that it contains
again if i'm carrying you know the
encyclopedia britannica or whatever
that's sort of a silly example in this
modern era
if i'm carrying you know a laptop chock
full
of interesting patterns of bits and
bytes all sorts of information and i
go into the black hole what happens to
the information that i carried across
the event horizon is it gone can it come
back that was the question that people
puzzled about for a very long time now
this animation that we just saw with
time slowing down
near the edge of a black hole hints at
an answer
the answer is well from the perspective
of somebody on the outside the
information doesn't
really get across the event horizon so
maybe
the information is stored on the edge of
the black hole and that resonates with
beckenstein's
realization that entropy
is measured by the area of the event
horizon
because entropy again can be thought of
as the amount of
hidden information information that say
has fallen in is no longer accessible
therefore
it's hidden beckenstein is saying well
it's
being described by the area of the event
horizon and now perhaps we can one step
further and say
it's not described only by the area
it's actually stored that's the new idea
that a tuft subscribe suggests it's
stored
on the surface of the black hole
and that suggests that the information
can get out
because if there's a copy of the
information on the edge of the black
hole then in principle
can be retrieved and this is the idea
of holography the holographic picture
throw something into the black hole yeah
from the
object's perspective it goes inside from
the external perspective it's on the
surface
from the external perspective you could
therefore retrieve that information it's
not on the other side of the event
horizon
it doesn't need to go faster than the
speed of light to get out
and therefore in principle you can
reconstruct
everything that fell in from that
data that that was the idea now
there are a lot of details
that this raises and i see a question
from one person that will help us get
there
hang on i saw it let me think about oh
seraphina t
all right serafina ts okay i saw a nova
program
was it mine recently about quantum
entanglement no that couldn't be mine if
it was recent i haven't done
things oh i know the program you're
talking about there is a program
i saw it advertise on quantum
entanglement uh
i don't understand how entanglement
doesn't travel fast in the speed of
light right good yeah that's a good
question
and that sort of will help us on our way
here so let me just
say a few words about entanglement in
general and then we'll go to
entanglement in a black hole
and then that will take us if i'm not
mistaken let me just
try to come up with a logical chain of
events that will get us
to an answer to the er equals epi yeah i
think that will get us all right let's
talk about entanglement for half a
second
and let me just talk to uh world science
festival folks in a minute i'm going to
ask if you can bring
if you can get your hands on that
entanglement animation that we often
have used with the spins
that would be useful so what is
entanglement first of all so
entanglement is us
idea in quantum mechanics that you can
have widely separated particles that act
as if they are right next to each other
they may start out life next to each
other you widely separate them now
normally when things are widely
separated you consider them to be
independent you consider them to be
autonomous
right in some sense the very definition
of autonomy
emerges from spatial separation
when things are so far apart that there
can't be any communication between them
between two given events someone
articulating a sentence in new york
someone articulating a sentence in
california if they are spoken
sufficiently close together in time that
there couldn't have been some
signal to correlate those statements and
they're independent statements they're
autonomous they
aren't they're not influenced and they
were not influenced by each other i
should say
now quantum mechanics offers a weird
rejoinder to that
because particles if they start out the
right way
can be linked in a manner that even when
they're far apart
they act as though they're next to each
other they act as though they are
influencing
each other they act as though they have
a deep
correlation between them and the
canonical example that we often use is
this notion of particle spin
you know particles always spin around
electrons have a spin known as a half i
mean higgs boson has a spin zero but
let's look at particles that actually
have a non-zero spin
an electron can spin we often call it if
it's spinning
from the perspective of i'm looking at
that particle right now if spinning
anti-clockwise counterclockwise called
spinning up
spinning the other way we call it
spinning down we call it spinning up and
spinning down so particles can spin up
or spin down
in quantum mechanics you can have a
weird mixture of a particle spinning up
and down simultaneously that's kind of
strange
totally weird but that's just like bread
and butter quantum mechanics so let's
take that
at face value the weirdness of
entanglement is that you can have two
particles and you can start them out
in a correlated manner spinning up and
spinning down simultaneously then you
can
widely separate them and here's where it
gets totally weird
they're widely separated each doing
their business
up and down now according to quantum
mechanics when you measure a system you
force it to empty up and pick one
outcome
so you go over to the particle say new
york you measure it and say it's
spinning up
the other particle california measure it
independently and say it's spinning down
but here's the thing if you look at both
the particles at the same time
let's see if i get the middle of frame
here right you measure the ones say
on one side of the country it spins up
the math says that the other particle
widely separated from the first will at
that very same moment
snap out of the fuzzy quantum mechanical
haze and spin down
even though you have done nothing to it
entanglement influences somehow bridging
the separation between particles do you
have that
visual guys we can bring that maybe if
you do if you don't if you don't it's
okay
oh good there it is see here are two
particles spinning up and spinning down
widely separated let's say you're going
to measure the one on the right and i
measure it and
the one on the left snaps out of the
haze and spin down that yellow line is
like a
a line of connection a line of quantum
entanglement and if i look away right
allow the particles to go back to their
fuzzy mixture of both spinning up and
spinning down at the same time
let me go over to the other particle and
measure it
i snap it out of the quantum haze say
the red
one and the blue one snaps out of the
haze too
even though i didn't do anything and
again these particles could be
on opposite opposite sides of the
laboratory
or the country or the universe according
to quantum mechanics you do something to
one and it
affects the other and that's of course
why
einstein called this spooky spooky
action at a distance totally totally
strange
all right now why is that relevant well
what i just showed you was bread and
butter
canonical quantum entanglement
in an ordinary setting my room
laboratory empty space whatever
it turns out that it's very interesting
to apply
this idea near the edge of a black hole
and that's really what stephen hawking
did what hawking
found in trying to disprove
beckenstein's idea that black holes have
entry what hawking found
is that when you include quantum effects
near the event horizon of a black hole
something weird happens so in quantum
mechanical
quantum mechanics particles can erupt
out of
the vacuum particle anti-particle pair
can erupt out of the vacuum they exist
for a moment
then they hit each other and they
quickly annihilate
but that kind of process quantum
agitation in the very
fabric of empty space itself this
is something that happens everywhere
now what hawking found is near the edge
of a black hole something curious can
happen because when this particle
anti-particle pair
forms sometimes one member of the pair
can get
sucked into the black hole the other
members outside it doesn't have a
partner with which to annihilate any
longer and it just rushes out into space
so let's see if we can we have that i
think we do have that kind of visual
don't we
yeah good so the red and the blue
particles here particle anti-particle
pairs
and you see the red ones are rushing
away the blue ones are
are falling in the particles can't
re-annihilate and go back
into empty space so this is this idea of
hawking radiation those red particles
hawking radiation quantum particle
fuminations particle antiparticle pair
created
particles or antipart whatever falls in
the particles rush away and go out now
that's the situation
ignoring quantum entanglement but when a
particle antiparticle pair forms they're
actually entangled just like the red and
the blue particles i showed you a moment
ago so the real picture
of what's going on if we can bring that
up is when the particle
antiparticle pair form they have
a thread of quantum entanglement
connecting them to each other
and in fact that's just one pair do i do
we have one with multiple
pairs firm yeah good here we go here's
with multiple pairs now look at what's
happening here you've got this
tremendous amount of entanglement
quantum entanglement
stretching right across the event
horizon
of the black hole
and so an interesting question is
how does the event horizon of the black
hole affect
those threads of quantum entanglement
that is a deep and interesting question
that people have struggled with
for for some time
and you can actually keep that picture
up i like that picture if you will
and uh and the question is for instance
could it be the case at the edge the
event horizon of a black hole
maybe it snaps those
threads of quantum entanglement now if
that were the case
you can imagine like a tense thread when
you snap it
energy is produced and if that were the
case
then there'd be energy
being produced at the edge of the black
hole this is what gives rise to
you may have heard of this idea of
firewalls
this possibility that has been floated
that the edge of a black hole might
actually be a firewall
because if those threads of quantum
entanglement were snapped the energy
there would be
a very hot create a very hot environment
that would be like there
being a firewall at that location
now why why would the threads be cut
well
from a general relativity standpoint
they shouldn't be cut because
the event horizon of a black hole isn't
something
in the general theory of relativity that
you can touch or smell or
hold it's a location of no return
but it's not signposted in any way
there's no
there's nothing unusual happening
at that region of space from any local
perspective i'm fond of saying we could
have all
earth itself could have fallen over the
edge of a black hole according to the
general theory of relativity we could
have fallen over
just now and we wouldn't notice anything
because the space that we call the event
horizon
is not a tangible thing at least in the
usual formulation of the general theory
of relativity but this perspective
would suggest that it might be but again
if you come at things from a purely
general relativity point of view you say
those lines of quantum mechanics will
not be cut
they simply extend right across
the event horizon so why would one think
they might be cut well
here's the thing those red particles on
the right hand side of that image
the hawking radiation for that radiation
to carry the information content
of everything that fell in to form the
black hole
that radiation needs itself to be
entangled
with other radiation that has come
out of the black hole if all that
radiation they're completely independent
not
entangled with each other then there's
no information content information
comes from the entangled
interrelationships between the radiation
the photons the particles that are
coming out
but there's a theorem that says that
i'll say it loosely there's a precise
version of it
the radiation particles can't both be
entangled among themselves
and with the blue particles inside you
can't have that kind of
threesome when it comes to entanglement
collections say two collections of
radiation particles and the blue
particles those are three collections of
particles they can't be all
mutually entangled this is this idea
that you
may have heard colorfully maybe
sillily if that's a word ridiculously
perhaps better
described as the monogamy of quantum
entanglement you can't have a threesome
and if that's the case if you believe
that the information does come out of
the black hole as gerard tuft and lenny
suskind have argued
if that information content you know
gets stored on the outside and can be
retrieved and indeed would come out with
the radiation if you believe that
is the case then you're in a bit of a
pickle
because you need the red particles to be
entangled among themselves
and you also need them to maintain with
a blue something's got to give
you can't have all that entanglement too
much entanglement
what do you do and so that's why some
have suggested that the entanglement
with the blue particles gets cut and
that's where this firewall
idea initially initially came from
there are other solutions that have more
recently been described
maybe i'll i'll get to them in a moment
but
i think that's enough to kind of
give a little bit of motivation to
uh xc's question
actually i didn't you probably didn't
know you were going to ask a question
that was going to um
take this long for me to answer but you
know
to get to the answer to your question of
einstein podolski rosen
and einstein rose and we need we need
kind of this background
so let me see if i can see if i can get
there
so let me let me there are three things
that i want to
say to get there number one is
[Music]
yeah i mean i einstein pedestrians i
think we have that that paper somewhere
in our list of visuals can we bring that
up i don't know if you can do that
is that it i don't have my glasses on
yeah there it is 1935.
so this is the 1935 paper of einstein
podolski and rosen
this is the paper in which quantum
entanglement no it wasn't really
discovered schrodinger knew about
quantum entanglement but this is a place
where
quantum entanglement was brought
to the uncomfortable attention of the
quantum mechanics community because
einstein said how could it be
that you could have these widely
separated particles and i realized i
didn't fully answer
whose question was it yeah seraphina
right so
serofina t asked how can you have these
widely separated particles communicating
and it doesn't break the speed of light
there so so let me let me just quickly
answer the answer to that question is
these two widely separated particles
their behaviors are correlated but we do
not believe that
one is sending information to the under
it's not saying i came out
down you got to come out up
rather at each widely separated location
where you do this experiment of
measuring the particle spin over and
over and over again you just have a
random list of results in new york up up
down down
up up whatever in california you'd have
another random list of results from
measuring the other particle
down down up up down down and so forth
no interesting information in any of
that data
the only interesting information comes
when you bring the two data sets
together
and compare them down up
down up up down up down you have perfect
correlation between them
but in order to do that comparison you
need the slower than
light communication channel you got to
bring them together
you can't do that comparison using
quantum entanglement you got to do it
with the ordinary means of comparing the
results
and so the weirdness the beauty the
insights of quantum entanglement can
only be extracted
by a slower than light comparison
and that's how quantum entanglement
squeaks by
the dictum from special relativity that
nothing go faster than the speed of
light good all right
i've closed that loop now let's go on
them so we have the epr paper moving it
back up
that's where this entanglement idea
really was brought to the fore
1935 this other paper by
einstein and rosen same year right can
you make it a little bit bigger yeah
thanks
because i i don't have any glasses here
i can't even see it but yeah this is a
paper
uh what does it say that says july
of 35 i can't even see um but this is a
another no received may may of 35 i see
um so so this is another paper of
einstein's
seemingly completely disconnected from
the epr
paper on quantum entanglement this is a
paper in which einstein and rosen
introduced this idea of wormholes
that you can have you know tunnels
through the fabric
of space connecting widely separated
regions and there is no suspicion
whatsoever that these papers had
anything to do with each other and
what ekke asked about
was the recent work and this is work due
to
people like suss kind who we spoke to
recently juan maldasena
many many others who deserve credit for
developing these ideas
that the idea that these two papers are
actually profoundly connected
to each other what's the rough idea and
then get to a visual
i can bring it up and guys just you know
i want to bring up the uh
the black hole wormhole entanglement
thing but what's the basic idea
look if you got two widely separated
particles okay
one way that you can imagine that
they're secretly connected
right is if there's a wormhole from one
to the other
if there's a wormhole that's a shortcut
that kind of brings the particles
together even though
in the real space that we see around us
they look like they're widely separated
that has the ring
of relevance to entanglement and tango
is widely separated particles that act
like they're next to each other
if there's a wormhole maybe they're
acting like they're next to each other
because
they secretly are next to each other
through the shortcut through the
wormhole that's the
that's the basic the basic idea now to
explain that a little bit further
there's one more
insight that i should give you this is
this
ads cft insight that you may have heard
something about
yeah actually lenny and i spoke about a
little bit this is this uh
insight that really made holography
something that the community fully
bought
into when lenny and gerard were talking
about these ideas
without a concrete realization of
these ideas they weren't as fully
embraced as they were post juan
maldasena's
breakthrough was that breakthrough he
showed
that in certain environments
anti-dissider space is the name but the
details don't really matter
in certain environments if you have
physics in some region of space
he showed using string theoretic ideas
that that is
absolutely equivalent to a dual
description
that only refers to the boundary of that
region
in fact a gravitational theory in the
so-called
bulk the volume of space is exactly
equivalent according to these ideas to a
non-gravitational theory
on the boundary of that region and
that's where the word the notion of
hologram
really comes in right boundary of the
region fully equivalent to the
3d stuff that's happening in the bulk
you know you have a hologram
2d piece of plastic you illuminate it
the correct way it creates a 3d image
that 3d image
is actually equivalent to the
two-dimensional piece of plastic
here the 3d physics would be totally
equivalent to say
the 2d physics on
the boundary now people then took this
further juan mark from romstock many
others
and noted the following i'll describe it
in words and then i'll bring home
see if i can bring up the visual so the
word description is this
if you take that the two black holes
imagine
black hole here black hole here right
each of them has a
dual description in terms of a quantum
mechanical theory on the boundary if you
then entangle
those quantum mechanical theories
connect them with those yellow lines of
quantum entanglement
it turns out that that's precisely
equivalent
to connecting the two black holes by
you guessed it a wormhole so a wormhole
connecting the two black holes that's
the er
einstein rosenbridge the wormhole
is equivalent to the epr
entanglement connection between the two
boundary
theories the two boundary descriptions
and i think we can can we bring up a
visual
yeah you guys are amazing thank you all
right so here's a black hole
a visual of a black hole and again
this black hole is equivalent
to a theory on the boundary which i'm
going to draw in red
here it's actually a thermal theory it's
a hot quantum mechanical theorist making
it red
there's a lot of sense in that imagine
how we got two black holes each
described by this thermal quantum
mechanical
theory in the boundary if we entangle
those two quantum mechanical theories
there are these yellow lines at quantum
entanglement that's equivalent to
joining
the two black holes by an einstein
rosen bridge a wormhole
so eki if i'm saying your name
correctly i'm sorry if i'm not there is
the answer to your question
you've got the epr the yellow lines of
quantum entanglement
and you got the er the einstein rosen
bridge the wormhole
connecting the two
black holes and so these two 1935
papers of einstein that at that time
seemed completely
separate disconnected they
are deeply connected according to these
ideas as
we just saw that's the basic idea oh you
know hold this you can hold that visual
for a moment don't go any further on
this and uh you know we're really
showing our full hand
again this is actually a sneak peek if
you can hold that without going any
further on the visual i'd appreciate it
or if you go all the way whatever so so
this is a sneak peek
of a program that we're doing world
science festival what you're seeing
right there
what you just saw is if you then
cut the lines of quantum entanglement
you can ask yourself if you break the
entanglement
in the quantum mechanical boundary
theory
what does that do in the interior
and the answer you can see in this image
right here
the interior kind of becomes pixelated
it gets pulled apart
so the fabric of space gets cut up into
individual chunks
that are no longer connected to each
other
so the idea and this is work developed
by mark
von romdock others as well the idea then
is that the threads of quantum
entanglement
may themselves be interpretable as the
threads that stitch together the very
fabric of space in the interior and
without the threads of quantum
entanglement
in the boundary quantum mechanical
theory the geometry
of the bulk theory balkanizes
falls apart into individual
chunks of space that are no longer
stitched together into the smooth
space-time fabric
that we are used to so that's the idea
that it's in its infancy but this idea
that
space time itself may not be fundamental
space time itself may be built up
from these more fine ingredients
the little blue dots little pixels that
you see
in that image and how do they get
stitched together
into this smooth fabric of space-time
that we all experience the answer is
they may get stitched together
they may get stitched together
by the threads of quantum entanglement
that is a fantastically beautiful
idea one of the most beautiful ideas
that i've seen in
in recent discoveries in physics very
much
a work in progress but if you were to
ask me
to look forward and think about where
physics is going in the not too distant
future
i would say that that is a likely
contender
that we will have descriptions of
physics in which space
and time as we usually describe them as
the smooth continuum
in the einsteinian approach
that spacetime itself may emerge
from a more fundamental starting point
and that fundamental starting point will
involve
some kind of ingredients like those
little blue dots
and only when those little blue dots are
stitched together by the threads of
quantum entanglement in the correct
pattern in the correct way will space
and time as einstein
thought about them will space and time
emerge that's the uh
that's the uh beautiful idea well i
guess we kind of answered
ecky's question er equals epr
i hope that did it
[Music]
i don't know you even know if ecky stuck
around
or easy or whatever it is stuck around
for the answer but i hope
i hope that was uh pretty clear
how all those parts fit together i saw
another question
roll by who is it um
i don't know if i can find it once
things roll by i can never find it well
i don't know who asked it
but there was a question someone asked
what is the page curve
i can try to answer that if anyone's
interested in that
anyone anyone want to hear a little bit
about the page curve
there's always a little bit of a time
delay so i don't even know if uh
and so maybe i'll i don't know i'm gonna
assume that someone's going to say yes
to uh
the page curve there we go many people
saying yes thank you
how could you say no to the page curve
well
[Music]
so don page is a brilliant physicist
he's been thinking about black holes for
decades
and he noted
in a manner well let me let me use the
visual imagery that that we've already
developed so remember i had that visual
not
not too long ago where i had you know
all the hawking radiation the red
particles on the outside of the black
hole all quantum entangled
with the blue particles that are inside
the black hole
in some sense what page noted was
you just can't have that much quantum
entanglement
what he really noted was that
when you appropriately define
entanglement
there's a kind of entropy associated
with it entanglement entropy is usually
called
and it's a measure in some sense of the
amount of
entanglement and what what
page was noting especially if you
believe that all the information comes
out
of a black hole in the language that he
was using he was noting that
at the beginning before the black hole
has emitted any hawking radiation
there's not going to be any entanglement
entropy because there's no
radiation on the outside for the black
hole to be entangled with good
toward the very end of the black hole's
life when it's really small and let's
say the black hole disappears even
let's say it's all turned into radiation
hawking radiation
again there can't be at that point any
entanglement entropy because it's now
the reverse it's all radiation no black
holes so how can they be entangled
so it starts out with no entanglement
entropy all black hole
it ends with no entanglement entropy all
radiation which means that somehow
as the entanglement entropy grows there
has to come a point where it turns
around and comes back down
and it's been a real puzzle for people
to fully understand
how that entanglement entropy follows
that curve and what's happened very
recently and we don't have any visual on
this we haven't developed any yet i
don't think
what's happened very recently is there
have been new calculations
undertaken that have provided
a means of calculating the entanglement
entropy
in a basically a completely geometrical
way
and people have found that when you do
it
correctly it's as if there is
a surface within the black hole itself
that
forms at late times after the black hole
has been around for a while
and that surface in some sense captures
the entropy of the particles
inside and sequesters them
from the entropy count and that's what
brings down the entanglement entropy
between
the external radiation and the
internal radiation
and that has finally allowed physicists
to calculate
from first principles this page curve
entanglement entropy goes up and goes
down
in a manner that agrees with the
expectation that it will have that
shape now the the beautiful thing
to some disturbing
but i think to most people pretty
wondrous and gratifying
is that many people thought that we
would need quantum gravity
to be able to calculate this page
we're talking about entanglement quantum
any quantum gravity with the thought
was but in reality you don't
general relativity itself
is so smart gravity is so insightful on
its own
that these calculations pure geometry
pearly geometrical calculations are able
to get the curve so in some sense
this has led some people and we have
discussed this with the conversation
with lenny suskin a little bit
to think that you know maybe general
relativity kind of
knows things about quantum
mechanics already and maybe that's why
the traditional approaches to quantizing
gravity
have failed because unlike electricity
and magnetism and the weak nuclear force
and the strong nuclear force which have
a classical description
which you then quantize and then it
agrees in that quantum mechanical
formulation with observations
gravity maybe it isn't a theory that you
start classically and then you quantize
maybe general relativity even the
classical theory is not so classical
after all maybe it sort of has
aspects of quantum mechanics somehow
woven into its basic structure
and therefore to apply the traditional
quantization schemes to gravity won't
work because it's not like gravity is
not like the other forces
it already has some quantum inside of it
so in some sense maybe
gravity and quantum mechanics are really
deeply linked kind of takes us back to
what we discussed at the outset this
gravitational induced collapse of the
wave
function i'm not saying that they're the
same by any means but this this notion
that
general relativity and quantum mechanics
are are
are kind of linked together profoundly
that's probably a correct
idea and i'd say that's certainly going
to be one of these ideas
going forward you know there's another
animation that
i know that we have somewhere it's kind
of fun we just made it for this other
program can you get that wormhole
octopus like um not animation but that i
think it's a still image that we have
yeah yeah that's kind of it's kind of
beautiful and and this kind of
illustrates this
notion of the entropy of the particles
inside the black hole somehow being
incorrectly described when we think
about it as independent
contribution to entropy independent
contribution
to these entropy calculations because
the notion would be
through wormholes these particles on the
inside are directly connected to the
outside
they're not as inside as you might have
thought and therefore dividing
up their contribution and thinking of it
as being an
inner part is wrong and thinking about
the inside being entangled with the
outside would be
in some sense an overcount because the
inside and the outside in some sense
would be identified would be the same
through these wormhole connections that
you see the wormholes are these
these kind of tube-like shapes that are
going from the
inside of the black hole to the external
space so this is another
version of that same idea
suggesting that the inside and the
outside are not as
logically separate as you might have
thought so that that is certainly
a very provocative idea that will
continue to be developed
as time goes by and again i would
consider this picture
to be again among the images that you
should have in mind when you think back
on 2020
right these are the ideas that were
developed
before the end of this year and will
have a great impact
going forward all right see if there's
some other questions that i might turn
to
um
so gideon omeda asks
uh my question is since molecules act
like waves in the double slit experiment
shouldn't the interaction between the
particles within the molecules
collapse their wave functions and yeah
it can
it certainly can be the case the self
interaction
of particles if
they are of the right sort can certainly
play the role of an observation
an observation need not be external it
can be internal in the sense that some
particles within a structure can act as
the disambiguating
interaction on other particles so yeah
you got to be real careful if you try to
do the double slit experiment with
larger collections of ingredients
you have to be careful about those kinds
of
interactions but people have
successfully done double slit experiment
with
larger structures you know usually there
are crystalline structure
where it can really be thought of as an
aggregate as opposed to
itself being a composite if it's a
sufficiently stable
and rigid molecular form
you can act as though it is a particle
in the double set experiment and indeed
they have successfully carried out these
kinds of double slit experiments with
larger molecules but fundamentally
speaking yeah you're absolutely right
um what else do we have if there is no
so raghav anand if there's no time
inside a black hole
how does its singularity exist i wasn't
saying that there's no time inside of
black hole sorry if it
if i made it sound that way what i was
saying is that the roles of space and
time interchange when
an observer falls over the edge of a
black hole so normally
you think about a radial direction going
from outside the black hole
hits the event horizon and keeps on
going to the center
that radial direction once you cross
over the event horizon has a different
character than you might have thought
the radial direction really becomes a
temporal
direction and that actually offers deep
insight
because you might ask like why is it
actually impossible
for something to escape once it falls
over the edge
of a black hole again hawking radiation
isn't really escaping the black hole
created at the edge and then it's flying
away something that falls over the edge
how how can it be argued that it cannot
escape
well once you think about the radial
direction as the temporal direction now
once the object
crosses the event horizon its motion
toward the singularity is through time
so for it to come back out it would have
to
reverse its motion through time
we're not too surprised by the inability
of objects
to not be able to reverse their motion
through time
that's not surprising based on our
understanding of how the world works
and so there is time inside the black
hole and it helps us explain why
something inevitably goes forward
because going forward is going to the
future
and just as you can't prevent yourself
from going from one moment to the next
to the next
neither can any entity that falls over
the edge of a black hole prevent itself
from going ever closer to the
singularity because that is going
from one moment to the next as
understood within the space-time
geometry within the event horizon of a
black hole
okay what else here um
that's kind of a good amount of ground
that we have
covered um let me see if there any other
good questions uh you know at some point
i gotta
gotta go inside and you know get cleaned
up and ready for our big new year's
party
not no not going anywhere
and i hope you aren't either those of
you who
i mean maybe some of you have any of you
actually spent
the new year's moment with us if you are
just uh just noted in the chat i'd be
i'd be deeply honored
and sorry that i didn't didn't note that
it was 12
midnight in your time zone but
uh yeah i hope no one is gonna go out
please don't go out
let's just beat this let's just beat
this virus
do everything we can to uh
prevent it from spreading further so uh
but no i can do a little bit more before
uh my energy just uh
is used up um all right
someone's asking uh repeatedly dinesh
ready
is time continuous or discrete
that is not suggesting that if you two
have a thousand question marks
in your question that i will address it
but it did catch my eye dinesh his time
continues to discreet
i you know i wish i could give a real
snappy answer
i don't know i don't know so
[Music]
obviously in the general theory of
relativity einstein
used the same kind of time that newton
was using the same kind of time
that we intuitively used which is this
continuous notion
of time now once quantum mechanics gets
into the story we're used to the fact
that
things that are continuous often do
become discrete
energy levels which can vary
continuously
in a classical description excuse me
energy levels do become discrete in many
quantum mechanical systems but it would
be a mistake to say that
everything becomes discrete quantum
mechanically it really does depend upon
the system and there isn't
you know if you crack open a textbook
on introductory quantum mechanics
yeah you'll see the quantization of
energy levels the quantization of
angular momentum is something that will
be covered
early on but you won't see the
quantization usually
of time or even position typically
and that's because there's no necessity
that space and time themselves become
discrete they have a quantum mechanical
incarnation they play a role in the
equations of
schrodinger right there's an x there's a
t
in those equations but those x and t
variables themselves
are not necessarily subject to
a discrete condition the way energy
levels in a box or energy levels in a
hydrogen atom
are now that's not to say that space and
time are not discrete so when we bring
gravity into the story in space and time
the cells become
intrinsically part of the quantum
mechanical substrate
some have wondered if they too become
discrete and there's some evidence in
principle for that idea and certain
formulations of string theory
there's a kind of discreteness that
comes in
there's a version of string theory
matrix theory in which space and time
are enhanced into matrix degrees of
freedom that
can be interpretable as having a kind of
discrete
quality to them but i would not say that
that
in any way seals the deal
that space and time are necessarily
discreet
in quantum mechanical description
of gravity waits to be seen but yes it's
a deep
uh it's a deep and uh
important questions so river thestral i
spent new years watching you hey
thank you i uh
i appreciate it greatly um i wish i had
some champagne to toast you i
i missed it no doubt probably half an
hour ago if not more
but uh thank you for doing that um
t gamer asks can excitation can an
excitation and space time field be a
graviton and yeah that's really
normally when we think about a graviton
that's really what we are thinking about
so what is gravity in the classical
description is warps and curves
in space the most
minut warpage the fundamental
packet of warpage would be a graviton
and that's very much
your language it's an excitation
the minimal excitation in space-time
would be a graviton in the more
conventional way of thinking about how
quantum mechanics and classical systems
talk to each other now again
i mentioned maybe it isn't exactly the
right way of thinking about things
because gravity
may itself have
inbuilt quantum mechanical qualities
that
ultimately will require a different kind
of language relative to the language
that we use when quantizing more
traditional
forces like the electromagnetic field
and so forth but
that's not a bad way of thinking about
things
uh afford d what's your thought on
girdle's incompleteness i'm already
answered that early on
ab hut like i answered that two and a
half hour hours ago
so i'm not going to answer it again
maybe you um maybe you asked the
question and then
went to get a snack and you missed the
response i'm not saying that the
response was
uber deep but i'm not going to deal with
that question again um
um what else do we have here um
ayush what is space expanding into well
it need not be expanding
into anything at all it can be that
space just expands and a space is
infinitely big
there may not be a container within
which we're thinking about it it may not
be encroaching
on space that is somehow out there and
has yet to be incorporated into reality
and we just need to sort of
reach out the tentacles in order to grab
do a land grab and bring that additional
space into the
realm of reality quite the contrary
could be
that space as it expands creates the new
space
there was this much space and then when
there was more and more and again that's
again limited by thinking about things
in a finite sense think about it
infinite
imagine space goes on infinitely far and
the distance between two objects is
finite
space stretches making those objects
further apart
the infinity of space would still be
infinite but yet
space itself would have stretch so there
are many ways of thinking about it
that's two of them you know infinite and
stretching
and that way no new space even though
space has expanded or
a finite region that's not inside an
external container
it stretches making the container itself
bigger
it is the container no external
container and that may be
where the new space comes from
all right i'm going to end on this
question luciana ramos what are you most
excited for in the future of physics
and quantum mechanics well
let me let me say two things
first is what we've already discussed
which is this idea that we may be on the
verge of
understanding the ingredients of space
and time right
the atoms of space and time and we're so
familiar that there's a very powerful
frame
for understanding matter which is the
atomic hypothesis right
richard feynman was once asked what is
the most important insight of our
age that if you were forced to boil it
down to a single sentence to pass on to
subsequent generations what would that
sentence be
and feynman said something like the
world is made of atoms
so that a high atomic that you know this
reductionist view
of the world now that reductionist
atomic perspective may apply to space
and time themselves
matter made of molecules and atoms space
and time may themselves be made up of
molecules and atoms these fundamental
entities that make up space-time itself
and if we were able to really understand
what those entities are
understand how they combine how they
stitch together maybe as we saw
through the threads of quantum
entanglement how they build up space and
time
as we know them as einstein described
them in the general theory of relativity
this would be
a monumental step forward what are those
you know moments that future generations
will
look back to and say aha that's when we
took
the leap forward so that is a blending
of quantum mechanics generality space
and time i think that's deeply exciting
going forward
in a more practical less abstract sense
i'll end on this
idea so i haven't said anything about
gravitational waves
um not for any good reason we just never
got there i didn't see a question
and it wasn't on my mental list of the
things that
really come to mind for breakthroughs of
this year
the big breakthrough in gravitational
waves was a handful of years ago when
the first gravitational waves were
finally detected by
ligo and those scientists the leaders of
ligo were rightly awarded with a nobel
prize a couple years ago i think it was
in 2017.
and and what's been happening there well
there
have been many subsequent detections of
gravitational waves
i don't know the exact number but it's
many dozens 50 60 i don't know something
like that
a lot has been learned about
astrophysical objects like collisions
between neutron stars
understood now gravitational waves and
so forth
what do i what do i see there that's
deeply
exciting well
in some sense ligo was
one more feather in albert einstein's
cap
i mean albert eisen just keeps coming
through with flying
colors right you know the cosmological
constant he introduces back in 1917
for cosmological considerations hubble's
observations of the expanding universe
convinces
einstein that was a mistake to introduce
the cosmological constant and yet 80
years later
we've now brought einstein's
cosmological constant back
in order to explain the accelerated
expansion of the universe i mean
a mistake in einstein's mind proves to
be
something correct einstein's math
shows the existence of black holes as
carl schwarzschild and others
showed and now look this year's nobel
prize
is for effectively the observation of
black holes
you know the motion of stars around the
center of our galaxy and of course we've
all seen the event horizon telescope
image of a black hole so again einstein
confirmed gravitational waves confirmed
it again einstein's papers in 1916 1918
and possible
ripples in the fabric of space that
would be
generated through the motion of
astrophysical sources
einstein again was deeply skeptical of
this idea
but you know astronomers intrepid
explorers
into the darkness of the unknown built
these detectors laser
interferometer gravitational wave
observatories
which have now detected gravitational
waves that's beautiful
as these gravitational wave experiments
become ever more precise
there is a chance that they will begin
to find
deviations from einstein's general
theory of relativity
either way it would be exciting if they
just confirm einstein and it's bread and
butter einstein all the way through so
be it
wow einstein the man but if
they begin to see deviations that would
be enormously exciting because
einstein's general theory relative this
is important
einstein's general theory of relativity
is one
theory in a class of theories
that in a very natural way adorn
einstein's bare bones mathematical
equation
with other ingredients that we now know
to be real qualities of the world for
instance the higgs field
that was confirmed at the large hadron
collider back in 2012
july 4 2012 involves this so-called
scalar field
a field that yields a particle that has
no spin
there are many variations on einstein's
general theory of relativity that
incorporates scalar fields in one way or
another this is an idea that people have
kicked around for 50 years brand's dicky
theory
among the first to incorporate a scalar
field
for well-motivated reasons into
einstein's theory no
evidence yet but if we begin to see
deviations from einstein's predictions
in highly refined gravitational wave
observations that would be so
exciting because it would open the door
to these other variations on einstein's
theory
which naturally emerged from particle
physics
string theory theories beyond the
standard model of particle physics
so who knows what will happen but if you
ask me
you know the long shot you know
breathtaking possibility
would be that einstein's ideas begin
to fail in describing
precision data and that ushers in
these variations on einstein's theory
that
are waiting in the wings we don't have
to really come up
with sparkling new ideas they've been
developed for half a century so that to
me is a
is a deeply
[Music]
exciting possibility when we're thinking
about the future of gravity quantum
mechanics
gravitational waves and so forth all
right guys
that is about it for me today unless
there's some question that just
completely captures my eyes i'm looking
there too many questions for me to
actually see me right now
so let me wish you all a happy new year
let's all
collectively hope that the world will
continue on the trajectory
of improvement i'm not going to get all
political honest here but
thank god we've got some improvement
here in the united states of america in
terms of leadership going forward
science will no doubt
rise higher in
the public conversation public dialogue
hopefully we will put to rest this idea
of alternate facts
there are facts about the world science
is really good at describing them and
predicting them and understanding them
and that's the
future of our species
relying upon those kinds of insights and
we're heading back
into the world of irrationality
with the success the miraculous success
as we began with of the vaccines
there's good hope that we will put all
this behind us and next time we will
react in a
better sensible way that contains things
so we don't go through this thing uh
this kind of pandemic again and so it
all is looking bright going forward so
with that i wish you all
a happy new year going forward we'll
have more of these programs
in the near future again please do sign
up for the world science festival
newsletter follow me
if you like i usually announce these
sessions on twitter
be green on twitter world facebook as
well
world science festival has its own
twitter and facebook accounts that i
encourage you to join and if you are
feeling generous
world science festival is a non-profit
undertaking
we rely upon the donations
from very generous foundations
corporations government entities as well
as
you folks the general public so
if you feel generous please go to the
world science festival webpage
and donate to us to keep these kinds of
programs
going forward all right that's about it
again
happy new year and we will see you again
for
our new slate of programs and
conversations in
the upcoming year brian greene signing
off for
20 20.
[Music]
you